hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta emisión agradecemos la
presencia de matías kulfas ministro de
desarrollo productivo de argentina
administro culpas muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en france 24 es un placer
tenerlo con nosotros uno de los
objetivos que se planteó el gobierno de
alberto fernández es que los salarios le
ganen a la infracción afrontar el costo
de vida en argentina es bastante difícil
no hay una importante parte de la
población que se encuentra por debajo de
la línea de la pobreza como están
abordando ministro de esta problemática
que involucra a varios actores verdad y
con intereses diversos y además es un
tema que suele disparar siempre el
clásico debate acerca de hasta dónde
hasta donde perdón avanza el estado en
algunas áreas
si tenemos la situación compleja en
materia de inflación saben que argentina
lamentablemente por diferentes problemas
estructurales no diría que sea una
cuestión solamente de la consultura
recordemos en el año 2019 que empezamos
el gobierno en diciembre ese año con
inflación fue el 53 por ciento fue la
más alta de 1991 y estamos trabajando
obviamente con el objetivo de poder
normalizar la situación y reduciendo la
nos va bien en 2020 en 91 hemos tenido
el impacto en las subas pesos
internacionales y cuando trabajando y
así luego de un pico fuerte que fue el
mes de marzo en ir reduciendo mes a mes
la inflación al mismo tiempo se ha
fortalecido la negociación salarial
estamos recuperando muchos de los
empleos perdidos en pandemia y granos
previos así que bueno esta conjunción de
inflación a la baja como estamos
viviendo después del mes de marzo con
suba de salarios y mejora el empleo lo
que nos permite adicionar una mejora
desarrollo real en argentina
asumió el cargo e inmediatamente se vino
la pandemia encima ministro que además
llegó precisamente a un país que ya se
encontraba en una profunda crisis que
sectores son los más afectados y cómo se
está trabajando con ellos
podemos tener una afectación sobre todo
en los sectores que más han tenido
dependencia de la vida social de la
movilidad de las personas obviamente ahí
está con la actividad turística que se
vio muy afectada como ocurrió en muchos
países del mundo la gastronomía la
actividad cultural buena parte del
comercio minorista hemos trabajado con
un paquete de ayuda que ha tenido que
ver primero con un programa que se llama
red pero que tiene básicamente un pago
de la parte una parte del salario de los
trabajadores de estos sectores afectados
y al mismo tiempo hemos generado líneas
de financiamiento para acercarles mucha
liquidez al sector sobre todo al sector
pyme pero en general estos sectores
afectados esto ha permitido sostener
buena parte de la activa productiva y
empleo si bien bueno es un sector que ha
perdido obviamente muchos empleos y hoy
estamos trabajando ya en políticas de
reactivación que hemos lanzado una
política se llama pre viaje que ha sido
exitosa el año pasado y que este año
esperamos a lo mismo que básicamente
consiste en un incentivo al consumo de
paquetes turísticos el mercado interno
justamente para este insecto a la
liquidez al sector y red retomar
a graduar la actividad turística en
argentina que como decía está más
afectadas por el coronavirus hablemos
ahora de la industria al servicio de la
salud no porque la pandemia hizo que
argentina y muchísimos otros países
también se lanzaran a prepararse y a
producir muchísimos insumos para
enfrentarla en este contexto del rol del
ministerio de desarrollo productivo
durante la pandemia es clave de verdad
que desarrollos se dieron en argentina
en este sentido
bueno efectivamente trabajamos en varios
aspectos uno tiene que ver con el
equipamiento médico la verdad que
estamos bastante contentos de que
argentina produce este respiradores que
es uno de los insumos más demandados en
hospitales el año pasado pudimos este
con un apoyo financiero de estos
elementos fortalecer nuestra fabricación
nacional de equipamiento médico y por
suerte nos pudimos rápidamente abastecer
todas las salas de terapia de argentina
e incluso su sector que está exportando
buena parte de esos respiradores a otros
países tanto de la región como del mundo
también trabajando lo que son los
insumos hospitalarios
textiles en lo que será el call en gel
trabajando en parte de venir con la
fabricación de las vacunas aquí en
argentina con acuerdos para fabricación
de sputnik y otras vacunas aquí en el
país y trabajando también en este nuevo
desarrollo así que bueno creemos que es
un sector que hasta ahora altura de
circunstancias argentinas y una
industria de la salud interesante y
pensamos que se va a fortalecer incluso
en el escenario post pandemia hablemos
ahora ministro de nuevos motores de las
economías verdad hablemos en particular
de la industria de cannabis el gobierno
argentino de hecho presentó un proyecto
quisiera preguntarle cuáles son sus ejes
principales y cómo está avanzando en
este sentido
es un proyecto que ya tiene media
sanción de la cámara de senadores
esperamos que pase pronto a diputados
para su tratamiento
básicamente es un proyecto de ley que
enviamos que éste legaliza la actividad
del cannabis para uso medicinal y el que
animó para uso industrial en argentina y
varios desarrollos tenemos una vasta
experiencia de mente en materia
agropecuaria también en redes de
investigación científicas tecnológicas y
parte industrial con lo cual estamos
esperando que esta industria que insisto
con una legalización sujeta a fuertes
controles la idea es crear una agencia
regulatoria que otorgue los permisos y
sobre todo trabajé mucho en trazabilidad
y calidad de producto bueno apunte a un
sector que bajara unos 10.000 puestos de
trabajo en un plazo relativamente breve
con un sector aspirando a una actividad
con 500 millones de dólares de actividad
económica y 50 millones de exportaciones
y es un sector que es nuevo en argentina
y bueno que busca avanzar también en un
escenario internacional de un producto
que es cada vez más demandado insistimos
buscamos estar con presencia en un nicho
de alta calidad trazabilidad y buenas
soluciones medicinales y terapéuticas
ahora desde el ministerio de desarrollo
no plantear una visión ambientalista y
sustentable para el desarrollo
productivo del país de hecho presentaron
hace poco lo que es el plan de
desarrollo productivo verde ministro
cómo se puede equilibrar el desarrollo
productivo y la protección al medio
ambiente
bueno solo pensamos que esto es más que
una necesidad casi una obligación porque
la verdad que los desafíos que plantea
el programa del cambio
climático nos lleva a este sin duda a
generar mecanismos de adecuación nuestro
plan tiene básicamente cuatro puntos el
primero tiene que ver con las nuevas
industrias verdes y estamos trabajando
en energías renovables en producción de
equipamiento para el sector que tiene
que ver con energía renovable con la
electromovilidad argentina es un
productor de litio tiene una gran
posibilidad de generar hidrógeno verde
en adaptaciones estos nuevos sectores
verdes de la economía el segundo es que
tiene que ver con la adaptación del
mundo de las empresas más pequeñas a
nuevas tecnologías compatibles con el
ambiente y estamos con un plan de pymes
verdes que tiene que ver justamente con
entregar financiamiento para reconvertir
las tecnologías y que sean compatibles
con el ambiente el tercer junto a
nuestro plan tiene que ver justamente
con el utilización sostenible de los
recursos naturales es decir trabajar en
lo que es minería que es algo central
para el desarrollo productivo a futuro
porque acá valoramos desde automóviles
eléctricos hablamos de autos para
consumir mucho más cobre mucho más litio
que los actuales hablamos también de
sectores que bueno que tienen que tener
una política ambiental que preserven los
aspectos centrales de contacto con la
naturaleza y este el cuarto punto tiene
que ver con la economía circular es algo
que está muy en boga en el mundo que
tiene que ver con un compromiso de toda
la cadena productiva para poder tratar
los residuos para poder tener un ciclo
de producto completo que permita el
reciclaje y también un tratamiento
compatible con el ambiente así que son
los cuatro que centrales estamos
trabajando ya muy activamente con una
muy buena receptividad por parte centro
productivo argentino
ahora otro programa en el que estaban
trabajando también desde la cartera que
usted encabeza tiene que ver con el
empleo joven no porque hay algunas
empresas que han manifestado dificultad
para conseguir jóvenes calificados
a qué atribuye usted esta problemática
hay varios elementos primero respecto al
empleo joven hay que tener en cuenta que
el problema del desempleo en argentina
está fuertemente focalizado en los
jóvenes s para dar ejemplos concretos de
cada dos desocupados que en argentina
uno es un joven de menos de 30 años y
que hay que focalizar las políticas y
por eso lanzamos un plan que tiene que
ver justamente con incentivos muy
concretos por parte del gobierno
nacional para que las pymes contraten
trabajadores más jóvenes aquí en
argentina luego hay dificultades que
tienen que ver con capacitación con
diferentes rigidez es que ha habido por
ahí que tiene que ver con recientemente
problemas de empleabilidad pero
insistimos es un tema que donde vamos
generando capacitación e incentivos
concretos el puesto de trabajo se puede
cubrir nuestra problemática a marc que
tiene que ver más que nada con generar
esos mecanismos y estamos trabajando en
esa dirección con buenos resultados
desde sectores de la oposición también
desde medios opositores en argentina
plantean que habría un problema de falta
de inversión extranjera a usted que le
responde
que eso no es así que argentina hoy
tiene por supuesto con las dificultades
macroeconómicas
que no son nuevas que llevan un tiempo
ya relevante hemos tenido una crisis
macroeconómica que se inició en abril de
2018 con una fuerte salida de capitales
esto lo que estamos hoy administrando
para revertirlo desde que se inició el
gobierno de alberto fernández en
diciembre de 2019 había una argentina
más de 900 anuncios de inversión por 35
mil millones de dólares de los cuales la
mitad son inversores internacionales
nuestros extranjeros y alguien tiene
ningún tipo de discriminación respecto
inversión nacional e inversión
extranjera hay muchísimos regímenes
sectorial estamos teniendo inversiones
muy importantes en la economía del
conocimiento en vez de una ley de
promoción que está funcionando con mucho
éxito por supuesto aspiramos a que esta
es una década de fuerte crecimiento de
la inversión en muchos sectores no
siquiera con recursos naturales ya
grandes oportunidades en el sector
industrial donde el sector automotriz
está encabezando una nueva oleada de
inversiones muy relevantes para el país
y también por supuesto en lo que es
economía el conocimiento como decía y
ahora volvemos una vez más a este
escenario pandémico no actual en
argentina nos encaminamos a un escenario
de aperturas que ayudan a por decirlo de
alguna manera a normalizar las
actividades y el desarrollo económico
del país por ejemplo se anunciaron ya
algunas pruebas pilotos para abrir el
turismo un sector muy afectado como
usted bien decía al comienzo de la
entrevista
sí así que tuvimos una segunda ola que
fue fuerte y está terminando no estamos
viendo desde hace varias semanas un
claro descenso en la cantidad de casos
un claro descenso en la mortalidad
del joven y la lava no por suerte creo
que todo el esfuerzo está dando sus
resultados y está bueno esta reversión
esa segunda zona esto nos permite
justamente ella proyectar una
recuperación mucho más fuerte en lo que
hace a los sectores más golpeados los
momentos de comercio minorista la
actividad cultura se está restableciendo
el centro gastronómico que estaban
obviamente mucho más restringidos se
están de a poco normalizando y aspiramos
a lo mismo con el tema del turismo donde
hemos lanzado como decía otros recién el
programa de pre viaje que es un
incentivo muy claro a ir contratando ya
futuros proyectos turísticos para que el
argentino empieza a moverse y bueno hay
obviamente con expectativa de recuperar
mucha responsabilidad el turismo
internacional sabemos que hay mucho
interés en los países limítrofes en
volver a hacer turismo en argentina o
los continuos 13 grandes posibilidades
así que bueno trabajando en eso
obviamente con todos los cuidados
necesarios queremos ser muy responsables
en esto pero vemos condiciones mucho
mejores matías kulfas ministro de
desarrollo productivo de argentina
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
la entrevista de france 24 que ustedes
ha sido un gusto hablar con ustedes no
por favor gracias a ustedes nuevamente a
nuestra audiencia como siempre la
invitamos a continuar informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y en
france mit y cuatro.com
[Música]